take it easy because it's time for my
ultimate slow cooking the slow cooking
is one of the best weapons in this chess
arsenal not only is it easy it's also an
incredible way to transform meat into
mouth-wateringly melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn first
up my phenomenal slow cooked beef short
ribs slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks these are beef short
ribs and there's basically five to six
bones across there and as the short rib
cooks if six that burn the bone implants
flavor and the meat just sort of melts
cooked slowly gives it that nice level
intensity slice alongside the bone stray
down you see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates I'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot seasoned beef
short ribs beautifully olive all in both
on the top will start coloring that in
[Music]
really important to give the beef short
rib a really nice sear if he didn't
brown the meat off it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that not only start rich
coloring just cut the garlic in half
slide that down the side it's gonna give
that beef an amazing flavor to give body
to the sauce stir in a heaped teaspoon
of tomato puree I'm just hitting the
bottom of the pan
but that's amount of puree and we call
it cooking out of smother puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of tartness for the
braised short ribs red wine in don't use
an expensive bottle of red wine there's
no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark rich intensity one of my garlic
that it's just a sweetener thing up
incredible stock in leave stock perfect
chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bringing up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they braise
from the bottom and steam from the top
into the other between half hours 170 to
180 degrees in she goes the great thing
about slow cooking is you do most of the
work in advance and then put your feet
up five or ten minutes before good beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is like cured pancetta
but what nice thick lardons nice big
thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious and chestnut
mushrooms I'm almost slicing just gonna
cut them in half
look at the color on those lardons now
all the whites
raw fat I've disappeared alarms are
shrunk right down and all we've got
there now is the proper bacon mushrooms
in beautiful so the mushrooms get
seasons from the bacon I'm pan frying
these separately to the beef so their
main crisp another different texture
leave that to cool down now this is like
Christmas day from it when you unwrap
that fall wait you see what's underneath
it
[Music]
mmm-hmm Wow I smell incredible lift
place on your tray beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices that nice
pureed garlic coming through there as
that it's gonna make the most amazing
slave scrape all that off the sieve nice
then just start sitting all that lovely
braising liquor well in
that smells delicious take your sauce
and just glaze do them individually they
deserve that respect spoon on your bacon
and your mushrooms you should be
generous with these mushrooms I'm
telling you they taste amazing flat leaf
parsley all that freshness over those
amazing ribs incredible never ever be
embarrassed about going to your butcher
and asking for cheap cuts because the
results are incredible amazing beef
braised short ribs with bacon and
mushrooms
mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients I use chestnut
mushrooms with the beef short ribs
because I love their firm texture nutty
taste but there's a huge range of other
mushrooms that are great for slow cooked
dishes and when it comes to buying them
there's one expert green grocer who's a
fountain of knowledge borough markets
Fred foster family oh really you get a
salad school with other 20 years of
experience you could actually write his
own mushroom encyclopedia mushrooms as
soon as you pick them the moisture
starts coming out of them
so you need to buy them when they're
fresh certain products you smell for
flavor and they tend to be fruits
mushrooms don't smell nice at all they
smell kind of metallic really so you
have to use your eyes as your guide of
what you buy the mushrooms really really
important wild mushrooms are literally
grown wild in the forests they're just
quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom a fantastic
products so hard to find in the world
it's almost got an apricot a type of
flavor earthy woody and of course as you
cook it the flavor increases for extra
flavor and texture highly prized morels
are ideal when added to slow cook stews
and casseroles as are the trumpet de
L'Amour which have a deliciously rich
flavor another wild type to try is the
Shan Trail it's subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't use water never
use wok with mushrooms it deteriorates
the mushroom rapidly oyster mushrooms
are very meaty mushroom just a lovely
silky smooth flavor really nice how do
you tell whether it's fresh those gills
are bright
never cut an oyster mushroom always tear
it little whiteness of that beautiful
that would be great if it was old
although also found wild oyster
mushrooms are more commonly cultivated
along with a similar type the enoki
their delicate taste is great in salads
and soups
finally Fred saved the best until last
the course of the pinnacle is the
truffle they are really really so often
the smell is so intense that smell it's
it's hard to describe because it's such
a unique smell the more expensive the
truffle the more intense the smell so
that's why you use such a small amount
on a dish it's amazing the way they get
these they used to use pigs of course
they don't do that anymore
they use dogsville because the pictures
to eat more this magical tasting fungi
is by weight one of the most expensive
foods in the world it's phenomenal eaten
raw shaved over pasta or risottos or
drizzle of truffle all turned slow cook
stews into something out of this world
people actually scared of mushrooms on
my say-so it's amazing really
they shouldn't be because take away the
fear and just close your eyes and taste
them they're just amazing there they are
amazing
[Music]
cooking all the ingredients in one dish
helps lock in taste and get great
flavors working together here are three
recipes that turned civil ingredients
into amazing dishes first up a
fantastically aromatic melt in the mouth
treat port make curry with mango salsa
for the curry paste and chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
kaffir lime leaves - a pestle and mortar
next put an aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander a pinch of salt black pepper
then bash it into a rough paste finally
add olive oil to loosen and your paste
is done now on to the pork neck add a
glug of olive oil to hot pan and brown
the diced meat carefully
make you short each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor removed and in
the same pan cook sliced onions little
brown around the edges at the curry
paste and fry to release all the intense
flavors then put the pork back in along
with a coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar more
kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and fish
sauce to taste then simply simmer for an
hour
[Music]
slow-cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful serve with
fresh mango salsa pork make curry my
next easy slow-cooked recipe is
incredible spicy Szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinate the thighs with soy sauce
and shouting wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry chicken thighs do a lot of work
so they need more cooking but cook
properly they're moist under the tasties
part of the bird next add rice vinegar
water and season and leave to marinate
for up to two hours
then chop garlic chili and ginger add
olive oil to a hot pan and fry until
softened add Szechuan peppercorns and
orange zest next add the marinated
chicken thighs along with the marinade
then throw in a pinch of sugar and fry
the chicken into as lovely and brown and
the sauce is deliciously thick
[Music]
at least with chopped spring onions at
lager soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
- marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free wonder
my final slow-cooked dish that
transforms simple ingredients into
unforgettable food is simple beef
brisket start by seizing the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the
breasts it's inexpensive but it's fitful
royalty with long slow cooking place it
into hot casserole dish with a little
olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns aromatic close and
freshly ground nutmeg
[Music]
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cooked low and slow the results are
amazing
tender melt in the mouth meat fantastic
with roast potatoes or in sandwiches
with lots of mustard but I like it best
with tangy piccalilli in the oven in
under 10 minutes then all you have to do
is sit back and wait so easy and
absolutely delicious what's not to love
about my succulent beef brisket 5 more
of my 100 tips to make your home cooking
easier
[Applause]
starting with how to cook duck breast
perfectly the slow way duck breast never
be scared about cooking this bird
absolute delicious very healthy first
oven on 200 degrees and then salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat nonstick pan no oil
but start the duck breasts in the pan
cold skin side down it feels and sounds
a little bit weird but we put them into
a cold pan and turn the heat up
gradually it starts to release the fat
if we put them into a hot pan it seals
them in and the fact stays in there we
want to render that fat down 90% of that
duck breast will be cooked on its skin
keeps a duck nice and moist but more
importantly it stays crispy once the fat
comes out turn the duck over nice high
hot heat seal the duck now they're going
in the oven
skin side down 200 6 to 8 minutes if
your pans got a plastic handle it then
transfer the duck breast onto a tray but
make sure you put the tray into the oven
to get hot first cooking duck is like
cooking a piece of beef and you can't
slice it piping hot all the goodness
runs out just quickly turn it over push
your fingers in there and it's slightly
resistant but still quite bouncy and
that confirms they're quite pink in the
center but the important part now is
leaving that to rest let them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fats and there you
go
next time you're selling potatoes you
just take them to a completely different
level now slicing the duck just slice it
an angle not too thin just ice it thinly
it goes cold quickly so a nice thick
slices nice crispy skin on top and a
beautiful plump roasted duck all the
white fat gone nice crispy skin
absolutely delicious another slow
cooking tip is when slow cooking stews
and casseroles fat will rise to the
surface to get rid of any excess oils my
tip is to remove them with kitchen paper
before serving this also works
brilliantly on gravies and sauces many
great slow cooked dishes start by
browning the meat as the meat cooks lots
of flavors get stuck to the pan to get
it into your sauce deglaze with wine
stock or vinegar never add soft herbs at
the beginning of slow cooking at all to
delicas the tip is to add them at the
end for that Hill fresh flavor and
vibrant color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry the skin side down to keep it
crispy and always later foot is away
from you when adding to the pan to vent
hot oil from splashing towards you
[Music]
slow-cooking isn't exclusive to just
savory dishes it's a clever way to
transform fruit into wonderful desserts
giving them an amazing sticky jammy
intensity invest a bit of patience and
my next recipe pays off big-time
indulgence and bursting with flavor
camera lies figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level a gentle long cook can
really bring out that wonderful rich
sticky sweetness and that depth of
flavor in fruit
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in rows take
some rosemary and just peel that down
get that really nice fragrance then get
your scissors trim the edge almost we've
got a bit of that sort of sharp point
bring your three Fink's
together and just thread at the top of
each fig nice and gently rows me works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor
beautiful
duster figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of balsamic
vinegar leave them to sit there for five
minutes and they sort of marinade I know
it sounds odd to use vinegar and your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste I'm gonna
make a really nice camel four or five
tablespoons sugar now flatten that out
and get it nice and even when the sugar
is even caramel cooks evenly it's
changing now you can see it melting from
the outside in the one thing you don't
do is shake the pan rapidly and sit
almost like sort of a lake defrosting
and it's hitting to the center bubbling
it's still not dark enough yet
it's getting there turn the gas down and
stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color for secret behind any good
camel is just stopping it from
overcooking lovely take that off the gas
and all the butter in there just gently
whisk in the butter is cooling the camel
down you'll see it changing color to
like a cafe au lait
next add a glug of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful or that nice dark richness of
the camel
don't touch a water in there that way
the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
your fix and sort of place them in
gently lovely and then just add all that
lovely little marinade mmm don't waste
that it's amazing stuff they're nice and
sugar and Boston vinegar
there's something so tasty baste those
figs because the skin gets nice and
crispy on the outside and the fig sort
of just absorbs the camel delicious so
easy now
into the oven 190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size now look at the
color on them the smell is incredible
onto your plate a lot heavier because
they've actually started the absorbing
that care now douse the figs with
caramel and serve with ricotta cheese
the freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well with the figs we've
finished that now this seems zest and
then some little nib to almonds and the
rich creamy Jam texture the fake with
the ricotta brilliant that is an amazing
way of slow roasting fruit and taking
face to completely new level
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details
go on get cooking